the first criterion um to being a leader
is you have to want to be one
because it comes with greater
responsibility it's like being a parent
right like having a kid is the fun part
that takes like
eight minutes right
uh
on
but raising a child for 18 years plus
that's the hard part well getting the
promotion moving into leadership that's
the easy part you go after dinner you
celebrate you have a glass of wine but
now being the leader is actually the
hard work
um and unlike your regular job which you
know
might be you know it has closing hours
and maybe you don't work on weekends if
you're a leader just like being a parent
it's it's an all the time job
and so if you choose to be a leader if
you choose this new lifestyle
you have to become a student i've never
met a great leader who thinks of
themselves
as an expert
all the great leaders i've ever met
think of themselves as students they
read articles they read books they watch
talks um they
they're constantly constantly talking
about it they go out for dinner with
friends or colleagues and they talk
about leadership and so you have to be a
student of leadership you have to start
your education so if you if this is
something that you aspire to then start
reading start watching start start
talking
well one thing make them work together
i shared incentives is also a part of
thing usually all we do is give
individual incentives which means we're
only incentivizing behavior to work
individually
um
uh
and by the way incentives don't always
have to be financial it can be just
recognition and reward you know catch
people doing things right so when you
see people helping each other and
sharing call it out publicly you know
compliment publicly criticize privately
um uh in front of the rest of the team
um
give people promotions when there's a
behavior that you want to promote like
like teaming um
but also as people to solve problems
together and
and and thank them together and if one
person comes to you and complains i'm
doing all the work you say well
why don't you find out what maybe
they're struggling maybe they're like we
have to push
push back
and also i think the most important
thing is leading by example
um
asking for help i mean when the leader
acts like they know everything and they
have all the answers then all it's doing
is telling everybody else you better
know everything and have all the answers
because that's how you're going to get
ahead here and so i think one of the
most difficult things for anybody in a
leadership position
to get comfortable with is is saying i
don't know or i need help or can
somebody help me or can you do this with
me
i love
working i love teaming with folks on on
my team
it doesn't matter what the rank
structure is bring in someone junior
let's work together
even if all they're doing is poking
holes you know do you think this is good
no i think you can better okay let me
try again
so i think i think demonstrating the
behavior that we want is a big part of
it
we take accountability away from people
and we don't even realize it so we're
actually destroying people's confidence
or ability to make decisions because we
keep answering their questions or making
decisions for them i had a boss many
years ago uh one of the best leaders i
ever had peter and tomaggio
and
he wouldn't answer a single question i
asked it drove me absolutely nuts hey
peter you know what should i do well
what do you think we should do
well i i'm i think we should do this he
goes well you should give that a try
then
you know or he would just ask me
questions he goes well have you
considered this i went
no he goes well maybe think about that
you know but he would never tell me the
answer he'd always tell me the
parameters
what he told me was self-reliance it was
the most valuable lesson i probably ever
ever learned
and very often you know somebody will
come and say you know should we go with
blue or green
i'll go with green will we just answer
the question let's say go with the one
you think we should go with
what should we do here make the decision
you think is the right decision to make
you know and then let them make the
decision and when we give people
accountability the amazing thing is they
rise to it yeah but we keep taking the
accountability because we keep answering
all the questions so there's a very easy
lesson for everyone here is um stop
replying to all the emails that you're
getting while you're away
right
like i know what happens you know in
every break or
right now
uh
you know there's an email that says you
know should we go with this one or that
one and you're replying and in every
break you're gonna reply to all your
emails and tell people your opinion of
what you think they should do versus
saying
i'm going away for a few days for this
conference so i can learn to be a better
leader um hold down the fort while i'm
away
if there's an emergency
figure it out
you know
um or only call me if you absolutely do
not know the answer
and stop replying to all the emails
and they now have to work you're giving
away
uh responsibility one of the reasons
they don't take responsibilities because
they don't give it to them